I remember you just reminded me about
the pod racing game on Xbox my dad was
addicted to that game and I think and I
think that's what made me fall in love
with like episode one well we're going
all the way back yeah
I do not give a [ __ ] what anyone says
pod racing is badass pod racing is
[ __ ] amazing yeah it's such a good
scene and the game is amazing as well
it's like burnout but with it's like
[ __ ] F0 and burnout but with pod
racing honestly it's it's yeah you kind
of you kind of said it right it's I
don't know why that was so hated yeah
was it jar jar was Jar Jar Binks that
bad I think it's because Anakin
Skywalker in it is [ __ ] annoying he's
a little [ __ ] he's [ __ ] annoying also
I think it's like all again all the old
heads are like you're not yeah he's cute
and whatever but he does turn into Darth
Vader so listen to your little [ __ ] yeah
listen to your little [ __ ] you're about
to be evil so [ __ ] you there's something
kind of annoying about like oh [ __ ]
child actor really okay
all right you think you think you're
good awesome very good films with like
shout outs like um JoJo rabbit was oh
that was the one directed by the guy who
directed Thor yeah it's the Hitler movie
yes yes I know that one this sounds
weird out of context
yeah yeah yeah uh it's um oh my God how
do you explain the movie uh it's like a
Let's uh have you ever seen like
promotion for this movie because it was
like everyone was like what the [ __ ]
what's it called Georgia rabbit JoJo is
really good yeah nothing to do with JoJo
yeah I figured yeah yeah
JoJo rabbit oh yes I have seen this yeah
yeah see everyone has seen this movie
but not everyone yeah I've never liked
that movie that's weird it's a good
movie oh yeah that is a Hitler movie
that's a good actor and that's very good
actually yeah I just I don't know maybe
it's the way that it's portrayed I hate
it when it's a kid movie and the kid is
like the savior of the world and I'm
like Home Alone
ah is he really there in that he's kind
of oh he's the savior of his will
yeah it's it's a great movie Shame Shame
what happened to the actors you know
have you watched um succession no yes
well I think we've talked about this
kind of why yeah we've talked about it
why why what did you want to say his
brother is amazing in it who's his
brothers Macaulay culkins yeah Karen
Karen McCulkin is it always I did not
know that his brother was in there I
didn't know he had a brother Macaulay
Culkin yeah yeah his brothers in in um
in a succession and he's amazing in it
oh so cool his brother's really [ __ ]
is he in succession the little [ __ ] oh
oh he looks like Macaulay Culkin I
didn't I didn't put that together [ __ ]
okay I was just naming it um
I don't remember it's the little [ __ ]
you know this is okay this is the
problem when I [ __ ] binge watch shows
no yes definitely I I I I [ __ ] forget
everything yeah get every character I
don't remember who's who I just remember
that Brian Cox is amazing yeah Brian Cox
yeah like ever since I started ever
since like the binge watching culture
took over just like mainstream culture
in general like they could be you could
be watching like [ __ ] 10 out of 10
shows but because you watch it in like
two days you're like I don't remember
anything about this like yeah okay
that's a that's a good point right yeah
okay also
finally anime we're gonna talk about it
finally all right so Sergio pop five
right yeah Georgia part five Ed weekly
and every week there was hype about the
new JoJo episode yeah yeah JoJo part six
dropped all in well half it dropped all
in one game yeah no one spoke about it
yeah at all that was like that was like
one week maybe where people were like oh
this is sick but then it just died down
no hype at all yeah I don't even think
it even like closely reached the hype no
not even close any previous JoJo no
right it was a bit it was a bit sad
because it was like I remember when JoJo
were part six what announced I was like
can't wait for the new memes yeah come
on jojo memes is always going to be a
thing that will persist throughout the
death of the universe and so many scenes
in part six that are just totally meme
worthy as well and then nothing and then
nothing yeah we haven't had there's no
hype or anything and when was it
supposed to I thought they said it was
gonna come on December the other part
but it didn't right yeah um
soon yeah it should I think it's coming
next season I will say watching the
first half of Jojo part six I was like
yeah I get it why this is like not a fan
favorite I did feel a little weaker than
the other parts right I don't know if
it's like Jojo fatigue I already enjoyed
it I really love it I just felt like
your part I know it's your favorite part
for me it didn't hit the same highs as
some of the other ones yet we've been at
half of it I mean to me to me like Jojo
part six it hit the ground like way
faster than JoJo part four yeah I agree
oh I agree totally yeah I was like wait
I was invested in Jolene and the setting
like way faster than I was in the
beginning of Jojo party yeah maybe I
should reserve my judgment until the
second half comes out and then I can I
mean the second half is [ __ ] Bonkers
yeah that's why I just felt yeah okay we
didn't really get anything we got like
the one a few really good scenes but a
lot of a lot of them I was like yeah but
it feels bad because I feel like if you
I remember when everyone praised Netflix
for their binge watching culture you
know they stuck it to the meta they
found found a new way to release shows
and I think now it's just kind of like
people are like wait actually I think we
had it right can we yeah can we go back
to weekly please I kind of like talking
about this with other people you know I
I kind of miss that because I feel like
there's so many shows now uh especially
in anime where if it's like stuck in a
certain jail whether it be Netflix jail
or Disney jail it just it's just a
guaranteed way to kill off any hype this
show will have you talk about bleach I'm
not talking about that I'm not talking
about I could be I could be but I'm like
one of my favorite anime that's airing
right now uh is summertime rendering and
that if you don't live in Japan you
can't watch it yeah because it's uh it's
it's on Disney plus but uh only in Japan
oh yeah only in Japan yeah I believe
like some Southeast Asian countries and
it's like by far one of the best shows
airing right now and unfortunately you
just can't [ __ ] watch it because it's
you know I think they're gonna drop it
all at once and I know when they do No
One's Gonna [ __ ] talk about it no
one's gonna talk about it I mean I think
like
do you think squid game was an outlier
because it feels like that was the last
time a show just dropped all at once and
just like garnered that's a case of it
reached such a global hype yeah it
didn't matter that it wasn't weekly like
it just reached to the point where it
became pop culture like immediate you
know what I mean yeah I feel like when
it gets to that point it doesn't really
matter because that's that's like
another Stratosphere yeah like that's
that's somewhere else I think actually
for that it works because I don't think
squid game would have been as popular if
it didn't air all at once was stranger
things weekly or did they just drop them
by season stranger things probably like
another outlier as well right uh yeah
but even then I don't think stranger
things
I mean the latest season it's hype as
[ __ ] though really yeah I haven't seen
anyone talking about what are we talking
about really it's like one of the most I
think it's like one of Netflix's most
profitable that's the problem right it
does really well on Netflix but no one
talks about it like everyone's talking
about like Better Call Saul yeah yeah
like everyone's to like chatting my ear
off on Bell Corso that's that's the big
hype show right every week you go back
you get ready you watch it yeah you
think about it and it's on your mind for
seven weeks because you watch all the
stranger things and then after a week
you're like oh what happened again yeah
yeah that's true right like I I think
because you get you let the chance for
like the hype to build up yeah if it's
like a well-known IP because I think the
reason it worked for squid game was
because it all dropped at once and I
don't think people would have watched
squid game if it aired weekly because
like why would you watch a random Korean
drama that you'd never heard of before
and uh you've never heard of these
actors or director or whatever before
but I think it was just in such a unique
position you know I was just like oh
there's this new Korean drama that's
just dropped It's [ __ ] amazing you
know I watched um bank heist career that
was really good what I think there's a
bank heist but I think it's from Brazil
I think it is originally from or one of
the I think it's Portuguese I could be
wrong right could we get a fact check on
that thank you thank you for that over
there
uh so yeah watch this really good just
check it out what is it about a bank
heist in Korea
that's it that's a money house
and uh yeah it's really good actually